how is life right now how it's
quarantine going for you kind of walking
through it
life is good yeah really good actually I
mean I think people I'm starting to lose
my mind definitely a little bit in
quarantine but I'm just like developing
like new routines and like new habits
and I'm actually getting to do stuff
that I normally don't get to do it's on
that my house actually in LA and there's
a bunch of us here so like what are we
you have to ask you about Julia Rose
because you guys broke up but then you
got back together so I want you to walk
me through what happened
I saw the billboard in your video which
was wild how much did that cost by the
way I think it was like - yeah kind of
walk me through what what happened like
what caused the break-up so we we were
just like arguing a lot over stupid
stuff and we just like realized like and
I was getting mad at her and then I was
being mean and she was being mean and
then it was just it just was a lot and
so yeah she was just like oh I need to
like step back from this then I was like
chasing after her and like a little bit
and she liked that and we kind of
realized that we got away from like our
roots which was like why we like first
like fell in love and we kind of just
went back to our roots and fix the
communication and fix some issues and
then we're we're great now so it's super
exciting so everything is good I know in
the past don't get mad at me
but people have wondered if your
relationships are authentic if you will
is this the real deal like you said you
drop the l-word just now yeah it's real
it's real for sure
yeah my oh my all the relationships yeah
there's a there's a line where some of
it's real and some of it's not but this
one's definitely real for sure and
what's cool about my relationship with
Julia is that for the most part for like
the first day like almost like six
months it was all off-camera I mean it
wasn't public or anything so that was
really cool and it's awesome to be able
to build like a relationship
off camera without like Hollywood and
all the critics and fans and drama and
all that stuff so our relationship does
a really solid foundation why have you
decided to start putting some of it on
on camera I think it's almost inevitable
because it's like I've always filled my
whole entire life it's hard what people
watch is my lifestyle essentially so
it's hard it would be harder to not film
it and make it like weird like if we're
all me something natural that's
happening and she's just like wants to
be involved with then can't it would
just make it weird so both of you guys
do post some I want to say like NSFW
stuff like either if it's in the videos
or if it's a picture like where do you
draw the line of what I mean you guys
joke about making a porn all the time
we have filmed the porno 250k likes on
this video and we'll release the photo
so we did do that so but it's like it
was just like you know I mean it was hot
but it's more so whether or not we're
dropping it which I which I don't would
think we are but my brother said he was
gonna start like a GoFundMe for fans to
like raise a certain amount of money for
us to drop it
would you ever drop something like that
like is there a line there
would she be okay with that I don't I
don't think so I think that's that
answer the line definitely gets drawn
maybe if the price is right how much
would it take for you to release it like
probably like five now five to ten
though five to ten million you and you
guys would just split it you would do it
yeah our generation like well I guess
like the kids growing up now and like
sort of me like we never had like any
big celebrity like sex tape leaking so
you would want to be that you would fill
that void I don't know I'd be the one to
fill the void but like I feel like we
need to stir the pot a little bit you
posted a video where her and Tana got
into a fake fight but then they started
making out those well how does Tana kind
of feel about all this you sort of moved
on
pretty quickly so were you in Tana the
real was that also real wouldn't get
anything to me yeah it wasn't it was how
do I say this
you're gonna tell anyone it should be me
I feel like I've been so involved at
this point yeah that's true it was not
listen we all do things sometimes and
some people sometimes you end up getting
fake married so I'll leave it that I get
your name tattooed on my ass
then we're boyfriend and girlfriend
again yes Julia said that she wanted you
to get a tattoo of her name on your body
did you end up doing that I didn't get
the tattoo of her name are you planning
to do that or no I might I might do that
okay all right all right
Marley get a second wedding out of you
that's really what I want to know so
I've talked about it with Julia and we
like definitely wouldn't get married
like on camera I think we would get
married for real and throw like a secret
wedding and then do one for camera like
soon or is this like way in the future I
think like in the future
how long in the future you better not go
and get married in two weeks I don't
think I'm doing that I don't know like I
might do it before the end of the year I
ain't scurred I ain't skirt I'm trying
to be a young dad you know what I'm
saying are you really I want to be like
a cool young dad you guys talked about
this yeah we were talking about it today
with our other friend he's like 21 and
his parents are like 38 and 39 that's
crazy yeah they give you a best friend
to think yeah I'ma be some big dope dad
my kids probably gonna be a troublemaker
though
[Music]